الحرب في اوكرانيا فتحت الباب واسعا امام
شركات التقنيه والسلاح الاصغر حجما
لمزاحمه كبريات الشركات صحيفه فاينانشل
تايمز البريطانيه قالت ان شركات مثل ميلان
روبوتيكس الاستونيه
واروفرمان الامريكيه التركيه بدات تنافس
شركات مثل لوكيد مارتن الامريكيه العملاقه
ومع طول الصراع في اوكرانيا بدات اوكرانيا
بالاستعانه بالشركات الصغيره والمتوسطه
نظرا لتاخر اقرار عقود الشركات الكبيره من
بين الاسلحه التي استغلتها اوكرانيا في
المواجهه مع روسيا الاقمار الصناعيه
المستعاره هي قادره على تغطيه مئات
الكيلومترات كما انها ارخص من نظراتها
التقليديه نوعا اخر من الاسلحه المستخدمه
هو المسيرات الانتحاريه وهي صغيره الحجم
كما نشاهد لدرجه
وضعها في الجيب تخيلوا بالامكان اطلاقها
ايضا باليد لدينا الطائرات المسيره وهي
سلاح اثبت فعاليته قبل واثناء الحرف في
اوكرانيا واخيرا العربات المسيره التي
تقوم بعده مهام منها الاستطلاع والقتال
وازاله الالغام واجلاء الضحايا نجاح هذه
الشركات يؤكد على التغييرات التي تجتاح
صناعه الدفاع لكن هل سيكون هذا النجاح
مستداما الفتره القادمه ستكشف لنا الجواب
لكن تجربه الولايات المتحده في حربي
العراق وايضا افغانستان اظهرت ان الشركات
المتوسطه والصغيره ربما تحاول القيام
باختراق هذا السوق الا ان الشركات الكبرى
تعود لتفرض سطوتها في النهايه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات